[Music]
yo what does that even mean
why
oh goku
it just means uh
in korean it just means country
really yeah
yeah so like uh
you know hanguk is korea
young is england
what about america
that's uh
that's my favorite one
meegook
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm nikki novak today we are
taking a second look with part two of
our greatest asian american milestones
list and these aren't just any old
movies we're talking certified fresh
film festival darling and oscar
contending flicks that have helped shape
the asian american cinematic landscape
over the past couple decades so join me
won't you because here we go
always be my maybe oh sorry i should
have told you rich people are done with
fancy clothes now it's all thousand
dollar t-shirts that look like they were
stolen off the homeless and kicking
things off as the first film on the list
is 2019's always be my maybe this
netflix film stars randall park and ali
wong who also co-wrote it with michael
the pair played childhood friends sasha
and marcus who have a falling out and
don't speak for 15 years they finally
cross paths again when sasha now a
celebrity chef in los angeles returns to
her hometown of san francisco to open a
new restaurant she eventually runs into
marcus a happily complacent musician
still living at home and working for his
dad and with the parent now living in
totally different worlds it makes it
even more difficult to reconnect this
film was directed by nanashka khan who
previously created the abc comedy fresh
off the boat a series ali wong also
co-wrote on for three seasons and
speaking of wong she now has multiple
highly successful netflix comedy
specials i'm talking a 100
on the tomato meter under her belt plus
she was included in time magazine's list
of the 100 most influential people of
2020 i mean she's doing well she first
met randall park in the late 1990s
through a mutual friend and they
remained in touch she said they worked
for years to develop this movie
describing it as our version of when
harry met sally i'll have what both of
them are having meanwhile park whose
star began to shine when he was a prank
replacement of jim halpert in an episode
of the office has now appeared in both
the mcu as agent jimmy wu and the dceu
as dr stephen shin
it is not the 100 most influential list
but this is incredibly
superhero adjacently impressive i'm
gonna die all alone in a big house all
by myself in complete utter and
deafening silence i can feel it marcus
they're there
they're there
that's all you got well i had more at
the beginning of your speech and then i
forgot it by the end
just so long
plus park gets to show off his rap
persona in this film which is based on
his earlier music career as a member of
the 1990s bay area hip-hop group called
illigan i'm not gonna rap for you you're
welcome
my mind actually
he also co-wrote several rap songs for
this film along with hip-hop producer
dan the automator a certified fresh
rating says that critics loved this one
with the consensus that always be my
maybe is carried by the infectious
charms of ally wong and randall park and
takes familiar rom-com beats and
cleverly layers in smart social
commentary to find its own sweet groove
searching my name is rosemary vic i'm
the detective sergeant assigned to your
daughter's case yeah good morning i've
been waiting for your call of course
we're working as fast as we can
i'm currently 35 minutes away from your
house but while i have you do you feel
comfortable telling me what you know
next up on this list of asian american
milestones is the 2018 mystery thriller
searching directed by anish shiganti and
his feature film debut this film is set
entirely on computer screens and
smartphones it follows a father played
by john cho who's trying to track down
his missing 16 year old daughter after
she disappears and the ensuing police
investigation turns up nothing he gets
some help from a police detective played
by debra messing and starts digging into
the one place the police ignored her
laptop i would think that would be the
first place they would look and he
begins to trace her digital footprints
and look for clues as to where she might
be see facebook isn't just for
complaining about stuffed guys and
posting your food the movie is
considered to be the first mainstream
hollywood thriller to be headlined by an
asian american actor in john cho who
actually turned down the role initially
because he didn't think the concept
would work as a film but alas he was
convinced and thank goodness for that
because he ended up earning a nomination
for best lead male at the independent
spirit awards for his performance
searching was originally conceived as an
eight-minute short film but after coming
up with the movie's intro filmmakers
felt like they had enough to go with to
make it a full length feature and to
make it happen searching was shot on
various devices including a gopro a
drone
news helicopters webcam and even
director anisha shaganti's iphone which
became the main camera to that i say
kids do try this at home it's my fault
for getting you involved in the first
place
i did it because we had already lost so
much time you cut me off every
professional who should be working on
this case
is working on this case oh all i'm
trying to do is to help you find my
daughter and while filming took just 13
days the movie spent nearly two years in
the edit phase building every single
website and social media platform you
see in the film from scratch with
animation and graphics but it seemed to
be worth it as the film pulled in over
75 million dollars with a budget below
900k this is the kind of money i want
plus with a certified fresh rating the
critics loved searching and especially
its star john cho with film critic wen
lima writing that after 20 years in the
industry he is finally bagging the kind
of starring roles he deserves
and the overall consensus from critics
is that searching's timely premise and
original execution are further bolstered
by well-rounded characters brought to
life by a very talented cast
the namesake
so uh
should we make our mothers happy and see
each other again
maybe
give me a call now we'll take it all the
way back to 2006 which kind of sounds
like a rap song which doesn't seem like
all that long ago till we tell you that
lupita nyong'o worked as an intern on
this film and i'm talking about the film
the namesake this drama was directed by
mira nair and features cal pen alongside
bollywood stars the late irfan khan and
taboo and follows a family of first
generation immigrants after moving from
the east indian state of west bengal to
new york penn's character who goes by
gogol was a baby when the family moved
and grew up like a typical american
teenager but is constantly working to
forge his own identity while not
forgetting his heritage and things
intensify for him as he takes his first
trip to india in his 20s pen came highly
recommended for the role both from his
former co-star john cho and also from
mira nair's son who is also a fan of
harold and kamar go to white castle as
one should be and the entire world is as
well
the namesake is based on the 2003 novel
of the same name by jampa lahiri who
actually hosted mira nair when portions
were filmed in india and much of
lahiri's extended family ended up
appearing in party and funeral scenes
and by the way that trip to india marked
the first time that taboo a longtime
bollywood star had ever seen
the taj mahal
a conversation starter do i remind you
of that night
not at all
you remind me of everything that
followed
every day since then
has been a gift
this certified fresh film and its
refreshingly real story was very well
received by fans and critics like critic
roxanna haddadi from pajiba who said the
namesake captures the interior struggle
between centuries of history and the
appeal of living only in the now and
it's grippingly beautiful and
overwhelmingly moving and the overall
consensus from critics is that this film
is an ambitious exploration of the
immigrant experience with a talented
cast that serves the material well
to all the boys i've loved before it's
weird and somewhat off-putting to be
congratulated on doing nothing more than
accepting a note and having an ass
pocket for someone to stick their hand
into
but i guess that's where my life has
taken me
and now to all the lovely viewers who
are watching right now i bring you
2018's to all the boys i've loved before
the netflix film directed by susan
johnson and written by sophia alvarez is
an adaptation of jenny han's 2014
best-selling novel of the same name it
stars alana condor as a teenage girl who
writes letters to all of her past loves
letters that are meant for her eyes only
but when they get sent out to the people
they're written about her life is turned
upside down as they begin to confront
her one by one this would be my real
life personal heart movie
not a rom-com
this marked a breakout performance for
condor who made her acting debut as
jubilee in the film x-men apocalypse a
couple years prior and then went on to
play coyomi in elita battle angel the
year after this movie released she was
paired with co-star noah centineo for
this one together the pair won the 2019
mtv movie and tv award for best
kiss a trophy cabinet stable for all
young actors out there plus they were up
for the teen choice award for choice
movie ship but lost out to that darn
lily reinhardt and cole sprouse for
riverdale wait this isn't about jen and
me at all no this is about you and josh
are you kidding me this is the reason
that you broke up with me you're still
in love with this
bonnie bear wannabe if laura jean broke
up with you it's probably because she's
coming to the life-altering revelation
that she's too good for you you're in
love with josh the film which was
co-produced by will smith and james
lasseter's overbrick entertainment was
followed by two certified fresh sequels
to all the boys p.s i still love you and
to all the boys always and forever with
condor and santineo returning for both
that's a lot of love but when it comes
to the first and highest scoring film in
the franchise the consensus from critics
is that to all the boys i've loved
before plays by the team rom-com rules
but the relatable characters and a
thoroughly charming cast more than make
up for a lack of surprises who needs
surprises in love be a predictable man
please
meet the patels when you talk to her
she may not know why you are talking to
her
don't be shy let me talk to her man
we'll support you
we'll support you
i'm telling you you guys are treating me
like i'm like
i'm i'm very good socially next up is
the romantic comedy documentary 2019's
meet the patels this film was directed
by siblings akita v patel and ravi b
patel and explores the expectations
surrounding marriage in their first
generation indian immigrant family
gita who's a filmmaker
follows her brother ravi an actor as he
goes on a quest to find a wife and make
his family happy as he approaches 30.
after breaking up with an american woman
audrey that he was secretly dating
without his parents knowledge robbie
goes on a trip to india and enlists his
family's health to find a wife in the
traditional indian way but things prove
difficult because audrey his first love
becomes his frame of reference for
finding a new partner the film
alternates between live-action
cinematography and animation sequences
of ravi breaking down events in his
dating and family life during interviews
with grita and the result was a film
that became an absolute film festival
darling it won get this the audience
choice award at the 2014 los angeles
film festival
named a top 10 audience favorite at the
hot docs canadian international film
festival earned the audience award at
the mosaic international south asian
film festival plus it was named best
documentary film and won the founders
grand prize for best film at the
traverse city film festival among other
accolades yes a lot it was a lot to say
it's a lot of
if i can't even say it all right i love
this picture this is the closest an
indian picture ever gets to kissing it
should be considered obscene by some
people
the critics loved it too like candace
frederick from real talk online who said
it's an authentic look at the sociology
of dating that we just don't talk about
enough especially among marginalized
cultures while the consensus from
critics in general is that meet the
patel's works on multiple levels
offering an applicable entertaining
documentary about one man looking for
love while posing thoughtful questions
about cultural assimilation and modern
romance
yellow rose this whole time
you were right here
when dad died
you know ma and i could have really used
your help i know i know blooming into
the next spot on this list is 2019's
musical drama yellow rose with
filipino-american film director diane
paragus at the helm this film follows
rose played by eva noblazada a filipina
illegal immigrant teenager who has
dreams of leaving her small town in
texas to become a country music singer
but when her mother played by princess
penzalen is detained by immigration rose
is forced to flee the scene and she
embarks on a journey of self-discovery
while searching for a new home in the
honky tonk world of austin texas the
film which dianne peragas had been
working on since 2004 also stars leia
salonga and dale watson and premiered at
the los angeles asian pacific film
festival in may of 2019. it went on to
win 13 film festival awards mostly in
recognition for august directing and the
performances by noglazada and salonga
also receiving a lot of love was the
soundtrack for this musical film which
features singing from paragus as well as
noblezada salanga and dale watson
left they're a little cheaper yeah
i like your notebook oh thanks
towns is like my spirit god
it's like dead flowers yeah
and after delay thanks to kobit 19 the
film eventually hit theaters in october
of 2020 becoming one of the first
filipino american films to be released
by a major hollywood studio for
theatrical release and with a certified
fresh score on the tomato meter the
response from critics was positive like
the ap's jake coyle who said that this
movie sings an affecting sorrowful and
defiant song where dreams collide with a
cruel reality and the overall consensus
from critics called yellow rose a
coming-of-age story with a timely twist
offering a fresh and sweetly rewarding
perspective on the immigrant experience
saving face
no way
we've been saving the next spot on our
list of asian american milestones for
this film 2004's saving face this
romantic dramedy marked the first
hollywood movie centered around chinese
americans since the joy luck club from
over a decade earlier in 1993 and it was
written and directed by alice wu in her
feature-length debut
the film focuses on wilhemina or will
played by michelle kruschick a young
chinese-american surgeon who is gay but
not out to her widowed mother or her
very traditional grandparents but the
tables are turned when will finds out
that her 48 year old mother is actually
pregnant and also moving in this puts a
little bit of a strain on will's
relationship with the openly gay vivien
played by lynn chen alice wu originally
began writing the story as a novel
inspired by her own experience coming
out as gay to her middle-aged mother it
eventually turned into a script and had
interest around hollywood but wu said
some studios wanted it to more closely
resemble films like my big fat greek
wedding or at least make some characters
white so they could add a big star like
scarlett johansson but wu didn't budge
and also made sure that the mandarin
dialogue lesbian romance and her
involvement both as writer and director
were non-negotiable
new machines
the script eventually caught the
attention of will smith and james
lasseter's overbrook entertainment who
produced the project and with a minimal
budget the film borrowed a helicopter
that was being used for smith's movie
hitch so they could shoot landscape
shots of new york and the certified
fresh saving face went on to be a hit
with both fans and critics with a
consensus from the latter saying that
it's a charming tale of a love affair
that overcomes cultural taboos
columbus truth is if i were in korea
i'd be expected to be there when he died
and to express sorrow
in the most dramatic fashion
there's this belief that if you're not
there when a family member dies
and not
adequately grieving sailing its way onto
our list next is the 2017 drama columbus
which actually has nothing to do with
boats or sailing i'm sorry for sailing
aficionados out there the film follows
jyn played by john cho who finds himself
stranded in columbus indiana when his
father an architecture scholar becomes
ill during a speaking tour while he's
there jyn starts up a friendship with
casey played by haley lou richardson a
local librarian and architecture
enthusiast together they explore both
the small town and their emotions
becoming ever more conflicted as they
grow closer columbus was written
directed and edited by koganata in his
feature film directorial debut after
years of making mostly documentary
shorts the filmmaker has since gone on
to write and direct the colin farrell
film after yang and direct the apple tv
plus series pachinko and it was actually
coconutta's wife who spotted haley lou
richardson on law and order and thought
she would be good for this movie which
also features michelle forbes rory
culkin and parker posey in supporting
roles the actors always take that
co-star on law and order you never know
thank you
for being here
i hope my mom's gonna be okay
she's gonna be all right
but one of the biggest stars of this
film was actually the location columbus
indiana known for its unique modern
architecture coconado once stopped
through on vacation and knew he wanted
to come back and make a movie there
which he did filming for 18 days in
august of
2016. the certified fresh flick
premiered at the sundance film festival
in january of 2017 and went on to become
one of the best films of the year
according to several critics including
kevin mayer from times uk who called it
brainian sensual cool and emotional
wildly impressive a coming-of-age drama
that consistently defies expectation and
the overall consensus from critics says
that columbus is wonderfully acted and
artfully composed and balances the clean
lines of architecture against the
messiness of love with tenderly moving
results
driveways the shelf is for a manga
collection for weird guys to live in our
house before us and he loves boxes and
boxes of it in the garage they're really
cool they're not really kids
do you love cancer you can't ask people
that's the best grandpa
pulling in nice and slow to the next
spot on our list is the 2019 drama
driveways this marks just the second
feature for director andrew ahn after
2016's fresh film spa night this one
revolves around a lonely young boy
played by lucas j who tags along with
his mother when she goes to clean out
the house of his late aunt there he
forms an unlikely friendship with a
retiree who lives next door played by
the late brian deneke the veteran actor
died a month before this film's release
and critics considered it an excellent
final performance on the other hand this
marked the first film role for lucas j
who previously had a recurring role on
fuller house and hong chow who plays
lucas jay's mom and is known for series
like big little lies and watchmen
emailed andrew han after seeing spa
night and said she would do anything he
wanted in his next film
driveways came from an original
screenplay by playwrights hannah boss
and paul thurine the story is pulled
from their own childhoods in the midwest
and more specifically when boss would
work in her mother's antique shop and
often had to go to people's homes after
they passed
can you come
sure
it'll be me mom and you
and there's going to be pizza there's
also going to be roller skating but you
don't have to do it you can just sit and
i'll probably just sit
don't you want to invite any young
people too the film had its world
premiere at the berlin film festival in
february of 2020 and its american
premiere in tribe back in april but it
was ultimately released via video on
demand instead of getting a theatrical
release due to the coded 19 pandemic
but with an impressive
catch this guys 99 on the tomato meter
this movie still managed to make an
impression on critics like david fear
from rolling stone who said for a movie
about isolation and the risk of reaching
out it's a generous example of how
nourishing a sense of connection really
is and the consensus from critics in
general says understated yet powerful
driveways is a character study anchored
in fundamental decency and a poignant
farewell to brian dennehy
[ __ ] you remember her
of course
keep it
really yeah i mean it's yours what am i
supposed to do with it
and finally the last film on this list
of asian american milestones is the 2017
drama goop this film was written and
directed by justin shawn a long time
actor who also stars in what is just his
second feature-length film as a director
after the 2015 comedy man up this one
tells the story of two korean-american
brothers who now own and operate their
father's struggling shoe store and the
surprising friendship that they have
formed with an 11 year old black girl
the film takes place during the first
day of the 1992 los angeles riots where
the brothers contemplate trying to
defend and save the store and what it
means to their own personal dreams and
the future of the family if they don't
justin chan who was 11 years old at the
time of the la riots decided movies like
do the right thing and boys in the hood
as major influences on this story
he wrote the role of his father in the
film mr kim specifically for his own
father retired actor sang chong it took
his dad three months to finally say yes
to his son given the nature of the film
and how close it hits to home
do we got anything to eat
nah they cleaned us out
got english money but i look like an atm
what you need lunch money for and i even
ditch it and justin wrote the part of
daniel just for david soh leaning into
his towns as a comedian and singer along
with acting it all came together when
the film premiered at the 2017 sundance
film festival in january of 2017 where
it picked up the best of next audience
award and critics loved this certified
fresh film as well like naomi wong from
little white lies who called it a
progressive refreshing take on the
unseen stories of the la riots while the
overall consensus from critic says from
its confrontational title to its
striking cinematography this raw
cinematic gem uncompromisingly proves
writer director actor justin shawn is a
filmmaker to watch i hope you enjoyed
our list of asian american milestones
part two and if you haven't caught part
one make sure to do so you're sure to
see it pop up on the channel and while
i'm not here to assign homework i will
say that your next assignment is to go
watch these they're all amazing thank
you for tuning in to rt essentials i'm
nikki novak
[Music]
[Music]